today we have a very special treat for
everybody watching because not only do
we have an exciting announcement but we
also finally cover a topic that I'm sure
many people have been waiting to see we
travel to the part of North America that
the Algonquin people call their home in
order to discuss a truly terrifying
legend an evil spirit that prowls the
northern forests of the Atlantic coast a
monster that can be found up and down
the Great Lakes region of the United
States in Canada the creature that I'm
referring to is part of the most famous
set of stories to originate from
Algonquin folklore these stories indeed
refer to the Wendigo some believed that
it was a large monster another saw it as
a spirit capable of possession the
manner in which the Windigo manifests
itself depends entirely on the beliefs
of the individual and the Algonquin can
be broken down into several groups of
indigenous people if we put aside the
one Digos appearance briefly there was a
general agreement as to what the Windigo
was and what it represented it is almost
always associated with cannibalism
famine and greed that came of the long
cold winters which is why so many saw it
as a malevolent supernatural entity so
what does the wendigo actually look like
there are two very distinct archetypes
that I'm sure many of you would
recognize a large looking demonic Beast
normally of the head or skull of a stag
complete or some kind of antlers or
horns this type of Wendigo is one that
has become quite popular today and it's
an image that I'm sure many of you
recognize from a lot of popular media
but this particular image seems to be a
more modern interpretation I remember
seeing this imagery when first watching
the TV show Hannibal which of course has
its own underlying themes of murder and
cannibalism at the time I didn't really
understand the Wendigo symbolism because
I didn't really know much about the
Windigo
and its own association of cannibalism
and acts of evil so why does this
version of the Wendigo have antlers and
fur reminiscent of a stag sadly I
couldn't really find a conclusive answer
there isn't much mention of the Wendigos
appearance in traditional Algonquin
folklore and what we do see certainly
doesn't describe a stag so there could
be some confusion between the concept of
the Navajos skinwalker or this very well
could be a modern stylistic
interpretation either way the stag is an
animal that appears in folklore all
around the world though it's normally
associated of woodland deities and
fertility
it's also an animal that the Native
Americans highly respected so if we do
go with the concept that the Wendigo was
seen as a symbol of corruption the fact
that it then manifests as an animal that
the natives held in such high regard
makes it seem as if nothing is safe from
the Wendigos curse which does highlight
the seriousness of the warnings and
meanings interwoven into these stories
the more traditional appearance of the
Wendigo is closer to a haggard and
decomposing corpse its skin is stretched
extremely tightly over its bones
creating a thin translucent layer of
desiccated flesh from which its bones
work ready to burst its complexion
varies from a sickly white to an ashy
gray it as long as spindly fingers with
sharp nails that it uses to tear its
victims into pieces the easiest way to
describe this type of Wendigo is as a
gaunt skeleton that looks like it has
risen from the grave
wherever the Wendigo goes it is followed
by the odor of death and decay it is a
vile creature with jagged misshapen
teeth that at times resemble yellow
fangs in this form the Windigo may be a
creature that resembles a humanoid but I
assure you they are nothing short of
anyone's worst nightmare there's an
interesting description that comes from
a new law that believed Wendigos were
giant creatures made of ice that would
dwarf over human beings and this was
because every time I went to go ate a
person they would grow in proportion to
the meal so the bigger the meal the
bigger they grew and this was one of the
ways they used to describe the Wendigos
insatiable hunger because it created
this vicious cycle where the more than
when they go consumed the bigger and
stronger they grew but it would have to
consume more and more to satisfy its
ever-growing hunger this definitely
gives us an interesting contrast you
have these enormous gluttonous creatures
and then you have these thin gaunt husks
that are wasting away but both still
suffer from starvation and that is what
we consider the curse of the wendi-go
it's hunger can never be sated its quest
for new victims is eternal when the
girls are always regarded as evil and
this is in no doubt because of the
cannibalistic nature but how does one
become such an evil entity there is the
belief that humans could turn into
Wendigos if they were overcome by greed
these stories are told as a way to
encourage moderation and essentially
scare individuals into behave in a
certain way those who committed
unspeakable acts of cannibalism were
also thought to become Wendigos and this
belief is where many attribute the start
of the wendi-go legend
there were however extremely dark times
where famine was so bad that people had
no choice but to resort to cannibalism
just in order to survive and make it
through the long cold winter it's not
really common today but in times of
extreme famine some of the Native
American people would perform a
ceremonial dance that involved wearing a
mask and dancing backwards behind the
drum this ceremony was mostly considered
to be a satirical way to reinforced the
seriousness of the Wendigo taboo many
saw the Wendigo as a metaphor that
represented imbalance and disharmony not
only in an individual but in society as
a whole this idea of selfishness does
also tile of the fact that when they
goes was seen as solitary creatures
often being referred to as spirits of
the lonely places so what makes the
Wendigo so special and why are we so
scared of them the possession of a
Windigo isn't like your generic spirit
or demon it chooses its victim very
carefully and slowly eats away at their
sanity it enters a thoughts and plagues
their mind of countless nightmares
unable to sleep they start experiencing
a burning sensation throughout their
entire body this has been described as
Wendigo fever and there have been
countless tales of people running stark
naked through forests at the dead of
night claiming that they have when they
go fever now as a supernatural entity
you'd expect some kind of supernatural
abilities and most of these are exactly
what you would imagine the Wendigo is
extremely fast and has unnatural
strength despite how frail some of them
may look as expert hunters they have
heightened endurance and senses making
it so they can hunt in all manner of
terrain and temperature the older the
Wendigo gets the stronger it becomes as
its corruption spreads through the
forests so does its influence on nature
some are capable of controlling woodland
creatures and others are so powerful
they can control the weather with the
eldest able to summon a darkness capable
of concealing the Sun making it so no
one is safe regardless of time or
location despite what we perceive to be
just stories there have been numerous
cases over the years of people
committing horrid crimes claiming that
they were possessed by a Wendigo in 1878
a Native American man named Swift runner
butchered and ate his entire family that
winter was said to have been
particularly harsh and Swift Ana's son
had sadly died because of the extreme
conditions now we don't know if Swift
Run and his family ate the boy to
survive but the mutilated remains of his
wife and five other children were later
found he eventually confessed to killing
and eating his entire
family but he was adamant that his
actions were due to a when do possession
so did devar and his son turned him into
a Wendigo did he butcher his family
because he felt they wouldn't survive
the winter or did he value the
self-preservation of his own life over
his families the answer to those
questions will most likely never know
another rather famous case is that of
jack fiddler and his brother joseph who
were arrested for the murder of over a
dozen people as the chief of his people
Jack was thought to be capable of
removing evil which is why he got away
of killing so many claiming that they
were all possessed by a Wendigo Jack
managed to escape captivity during a
routine walk outside and he eventually
hung himself before the trial came to a
conclusion his brother Joseph however
wasn't so lucky
he was sentenced to death by magistrate
Ellsworth Perry despite the numerous
appeals of his innocence Joseph
ironically enough was eventually given a
pardon but it came three days after his
death in 1909 these type of cases led
people to believe that it might be a
more serious mental issue one that would
later be dubbed Wendigo psychosis the
deep craving for flesh but whether it
was a real mental disorder is something
that was heavily debated as the number
of reported cases decreased dramatically
in the 20th century when the Algonquin
people adapted to European ideologies
and began to live less rural lifestyles
there's no doubt that the Wendigo myth
has changed and evolved over the years
it's now become another monster that
reflects our issues as humans greed
selfishness and in some extreme or
metaphoric cases cannibalism it's
unlikely that many of the Native
American tribes still believe in the
legends of the Wendigo as adamantly as
they once did to them the Wendigo was an
evil spirit that embodied everything
they hated it can be interpreted as a
symbol of corruption from what they
perceived to be outsiders
changing their landscape in the beliefs
of their people stories of the Wendigo
were used as a way to encourage a
balanced lifestyle and respect for one's
peers and the world surrounding them a
creature with insatiable hunger a spirit
capable of possession or a story meant
to encourage cooperation and warned
against the dangers of greed you decide
before we do n today's video I'd like to
tell you about our new series of short
stories that I'll be publishing over the
Christmas and New Year period in the
build-up to our book release the stories
themselves are in a completely different
universe and part of an entirely
separate project but I feel like it's a
great opportunity to show you the style
of writing as the author other stories
is also the co-author of the book it's
also really nice to give you guys a
sneak peek into the future projects that
we are in fact working on for those
who've been asking me to narrate more
stories and creepy passages I'm sure
this is a series that you'll definitely
enjoy so keep an eye out for episode 1
of our dark world series curse of the
wendi-go as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explain
[Music]